le geste est maladroit mais virgile est
venu découvrir des métiers auxquels ils
n'auraient pas pensé comme ici sur le
stand de la petite enfance vrai dire en
fait on vient découvrir surtout
aujourd'hui les métiers plusieurs
métiers donc pourquoi nous orienter
votre verre notre avenir pour savoir ce
qu'on va faire plus tard et justement
ici on a on a vu les métiers de la
petite enfance qui peuvent atteindre
être intéressant pour certaines
personnes louison étaient les 25e
elle vient se confronter à la mécanique
automobile ça nous permet de découvrir
plein de métiers que on entend peut-être
pas trop parler là va pouvoir utiliser
tes doigts pour partir droit en plus et
ensuite coupé appréhender et tester les
gestes techniques
c'est surtout ce que propose le salon
des métiers quand on est apprenti on est
à 200% dans l'entreprise on sait ce que
c'est que le travail est un cv
aujourd'hui vous avez un élève qui sort
de lycées professionnels et un élèves
qui sortent de ces apps est en
apprentissage cuisine il fera
certainement la différence ici il a la
motivation bien évidemment aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment l'occasion plutôt de
démarré par la découverte des métiers et
voir si certains métiers sont plutôt
fait pour nous en fonction de nos
aptitudes de nos envies de nos attentes
de ce qu'on aime faire travailler à
l'extérieur à l'intérieur un métier
manuel pas balayer les idées reçues ce
stand propose de porter un autre regard
sur les métiers du transport et de la
logistique grâce à un simulateur virtuel
on encourage que je suis en a beaucoup
sur ces salons à se diriger vers les
formations qui vont intégrer
des métiers soit de la conduite de
l'exploitation c'est à dire de
l'organisation des transports et de la
logistique
mais tous ne s'arrache pas les cheveux
pour leur orientation
j'aimerais bien qu'ils ne semblent pas
furent comme ma mamie pour ceux qui
n'ont pas encore choisi le salon sera
ouvert demain et il y aura une session
de rattrapage les 26 et 27 mars
prochains à champagnole dans le jura